Critics on the left often use the straw
man of TDS Trump derangement syndrome
uh why does Donald Trump arouse so much
emotion in people
it's just the nature of the person I
mean I don't feel particularly emotional
about him
um I mean he's kind of a
he's a very flawed guy to be honest on
this may seem bizarre I felt sorry for
him because this guy is so vulnerable
so wrapped upon himself
that I mean he's just exquisitely
open to manipulation and I saw people
taking advantage of him all the time he
has zero self-awareness
I mean I kept thinking to myself my God
if this guy didn't have this Entourage
around him how would he function
I mean I felt sorry for us as well I
mean that he ended up being our
President because that should not have
happened I mean in terms of character
and in terms of fit for fit for the job
although I saw this you know kind of
over a period of time but I didn't feel
you know kind of
any you know
a sense of derangement you know kind of
around him I didn't drive me nuts in
that way I just became I was just very
worried about you know the kind of the
impact that he was having on on many
particular issues here's the important
thing so what I noticed that people that
criticized Donald Trump
is they get caught up in the momentum of
it and they're unable to see
um
first of all let's start with some
ground truth which is
approximately
half the country voted for the guy
right yep and Maul voted in 2020 than
voted in 2016 for it yeah
and I I just I just feel like people
don't load that in when they're honestly
a lot of those people
didn't vote for
him and his personality and often could
because I know a lot of people voted for
him
but first time and second time
and they could disassociate
you know kind of the all of the kind of
features of Donald Trump that drives
other people nuts from you know what
they thought that an actual fact he
could achieve in terms of it wasn't just
this kind of sense about well I couldn't
possibly vote for Democrats sometimes
it's just like well look you shake
things up and we need things to check to
be shoken up and um some people might
have voted him for personality see this
one yeah some of them know some of them
did as well but I'm just thinking that
not all of them did either that's the
thing but yeah I can't say I'm just I'm
just saying anecdotally I know people
who voted me because he's him from the
Charisma and another two voted because
he's shaking things up and you know he's
keeping people on their toes and you
know kind of we need that you know idea
but the way to avoid Trump derangement
syndrome to me me as a doctor I'm sort
of prescribing to the patients uh on
this syndrome this uh this issue is I
feel like you have to empathize
with the people you have to imagine your
mind all the different like um
strengths that the people who have voted
for Donald Trump see
and really understand it really feel it
like walk around with it and then
criticize like I just feel like people
get lost in this bubble of criticism in
their own head I forget like the tribe
you're in or whatever in their own head
they're not able to see like half this
country that we're a part of voted for
the person same with Biden half the
country voted for the guy the people
that are criticizing blind and they're
doing this the way Biden is currently
criticized
is not based on policy
uh is based on personal stuff similar
like to Trump yeah I know it is I mean
that's what people do look I think part
of that is
I mean I look at first of all I want to
say I completely agree with you about
understanding my own people are coming
from I think it's very important for
people to listen to other people and
their views I try to do that all the
time try to learn from that you know I
mean everybody's got a a perspective and
a context we all live in a certain
context we're all living in history our
own personal histories matter a lot and
also the larger context the environment
in which we're living in and where we
live and who we live with and you know
the kinds of lives that we lead as well
those are all extraordinarily important
I mean I know that from you know myself
everything you know that I've done in my
life has been shipped by where I came
from who I was my family and the way
that we looked at things you can't take
yourself out of that I mean you can do
it in some you know like a science or
something else but you know it's still
your own views and maybe some of the
ideas that you have and pursuing an
experiment might have been shaped by
your larger context you know depending
on what it is that you work on but the
other thing is the niche of the
political system
the presidential election is like
a personality contest a beauty contest
it's like a kind of a referendum on you
know one person or another
it's kind of like what we see in Russia
honesty with you know Putin or not Putin
or Putin and put before you know it's
all about Putin and you know what do you
think about Putin it's not about what
the President should be doing and you
know kind of what their policies are
that's kind of the bizareness of the US
political system look we've just seen
this happening in the United Kingdom
you've got this core of a couple of
thousand a couple hundred thousand
rather uh people in the conservative
party have just voted for you know three
leaders in a row the rest of the country
isn't and they're just looking at you
know whether like that personality and
you know what they said to them rather
than what they're necessarily going to
do for the country
I mean which is you know kind of pretty
absurd and I mean again the presidency
is a weird hybrid in the United States
you know we were talking before about
it's the person you should be running
the country to the chief executive or
the prime minister in another setting
but we don't think of it like that you
know we often think about whether we
like the guy or not so you know we'd
like to hang out with them all the you
know one of my younger relatives and I
said so why did you vote for Trump he
said well he was great it's funny how
much of his rallies I got you know all
kind of charged up and I said could you
see yourself voting for Biden or he's
Two Worlds and I simply no he's only
just a little bit you know kind of older
than Trump or is you know the same
emergency grandma do you think your
Grandma's old no no not at all but it's
just this kind of perception he's boring
you know so there's people are actually
sometimes you know basically being you
know kind of uh motivated by just a
feeling you know kind of that kind of
sense because that's the sort of nature
of the you know the presidency it's this
kind of how you feel about yourself as
an American or how you feel about the
country very large the kind of a symbol
of the state look at you know in Britney
you had you know Queen Elizabeth II and
everyone body you know seem to for the
most part I know everyone I guess but
most people respected her as a person as
a personality as a kind of symbol of
this day even if they actually didn't
really like the institution of the
monarchy there was something you know
kind of about that particular
personality that you were able to you
know kind of relate to in that context
but only the United States we've got all
that rolled into one the head of state
the symbol of the state the kind of the
Queen the king the kind of idea the
chief executive the kind of prime
ministerial role and then the Commander
in Chief of the military it's all things
you know kind of at once but ultimately
for a lot of people it's just how we
feel about that person oh I couldn't
cover up for them because of this or I
couldn't vote for them because of that
and in 2016
I know Hillary Clinton actually did win
the election in terms of the popular
vote so it wasn't that you know kind of
people wouldn't vote for a woman I mean
more people voted for her
on the popular level not obviously you
know through the Electoral College in
the Electoral College vote so it wasn't
just you know gender or something like
that but it was an awful lot of things
for people found Trump attractive
because he was sticking up the big
middle finger to The Establishment he's
an anti-establishment change character
there's a lot of people voted for Barack
Obama for the same reason and voted for
Trump we know that phenomenon what was
the 11 you know 12 of people you know so
they could vote for some completely
totally different vertically different
people because that sense of change and
Charisma I mean I had people who I knew
voter for Trump but would have voted for
a bummer again if he'd run again uh
because they just like the way that he
spoke they like the way that you know
because they said um
I mean this is all my own anecdotal
things do it about one of my relatives
said I could listen to a bummer all day
every day I just love the way he sounded
I love the way he looked you know I was
just like the whole thing about him and
then say about Trump while he was
exciting it was interesting you know he
was kind of like you know whipping it up
there you know so there's this just this
kind of feeling you know we always say
about you know could you have a beer
with this person and people a lot of
people decide they couldn't have one
with Hillary Clinton and you know maybe
they could go off and have one with
Barack Obama and uh with uh Donald Trump
they didn't want to have one with Joe
Biden you know for example and remember
George W bush didn't drink so he
wouldn't have had a beer with him he'd
have gone out and got a soda or
something with him but you know there's
this there's that kind of element of
just that sort of personal connection in
the way that the whole presidential
election is set up it's less about the
parties
it says about the platforms it's more
about the person
yeah and picking one side and like
sticking with your person really like a
sport team yeah it is yeah